the new loki series on disney plus
starring tom hiddleston
is setting out to explore where the god
of mischief disappeared to
when he grabbed the tesseract during
avengers end game
scratching your head after the show's
premier episode here's the end of loki
episode 1 explained
from the jump loki is making something
very clear this will be an in-depth dive
into what makes a god of mischief tick
this is a version of the character who
was apprehended just after the events of
the avengers after all
so he hasn't had the huge redemption arc
through thor the dark world
thor ragnarok and avengers infinity war
it's been a very long day and i think
i've had my fill of idiots in armoured
suits telling me what to do
so when the time variant authority picks
loki up in the gobi desert in mongolia
he's not exactly cooperative which makes
it pretty fun when one of the hunters
knocks him out in slow motion
before resetting the timeline with a
device called a reset charge
and karting him after the tva's
headquarters when loki arrives at the
tva's offices
he's constantly trying to fight them off
on escape his selfish manipulative
nature bleeds through every single
conversation he has
no matter who he's speaking to and later
when the judge is sentencing loki for
his crimes against the timeline
he's still trying to worm his way out of
the situation and pass the blame on to
someone else
it's classic loki but the tva refers to
him as variant l1130 because it's
important to remember that the series
isn't following the main version of loki
the one who was killed by thanos in
avengers infinity war
when the hunters used their reset charge
in mongolia
they closed the new timeline branch loki
created when he escaped with the
tesseract however
it's not entirely clear just how far the
effects of reset charge go
as the judge tells loki during his trial
the avengers were supposed to go back in
time to retrieve the infinity stones
so just how far back did this particular
repair of the timeline go
regardless of the overall effects of the
reset charge thanks to the intervention
of agent mobius
this mischievous loki variant is allowed
to live at least for now
owen wilson is a breath of fresh air in
the mcu as
agent mobius he's a welcome addition
here as his laid-back casual nature
helps the weirder elements of the series
go down a little easier
loki introduces mobius as he's in the
middle of hunting a particularly violent
variant
in france in 1549 although the writers
are careful not to mention
exactly who this variant is although the
bureaucratic nature of the tva might
make its employees seem a little cold
mobius clearly has a softer side which
we see when he tries to get more
information from the french child
about what happened in the church and
who killed the hunters
the kid ominously points towards the
stained glass window depicting the devil
and who else is well known for wearing a
set of horns in the mcu
you guessed it anyway as entertaining as
he is mobius has a crucial role in the
show
he's smoothing over any questions that
loki or the viewer might have about the
tva
and what they do he's also the stepping
stone to understanding loki on a
psychological level
as he does a massive job of getting
under his skin in one of the best scenes
in the episode
when mobius takes loki into a room
called the time theater
the pair rewatched some of the key
moments in the god of mischief's life
this includes a brilliant scene where
loki is revealed to have been db cooper
the real life man responsible for
hijacking a plane in the 1970s
for a 200 000 ransom before seemingly
disappearing
the answer to this bizarre historical
mystery heimdall pulled loki out of the
sky
using the bifrust yes that's hilarious
but it's only to catch audiences off
guard
as a conversation takes a much deeper
turn and puts loki's lifelong
motivations
under the microscope specifically his
desire to rule
why is loki like this why does he want
to rule midgard the nine realms and
asgard itself
the former prince is forced to take a
long hard look at himself
and the ramifications of his actions
even reckoning with the fact that he's
destined to get his own mother killed
by sending the dark elves up a specific
set of stairs
in thor the dark world but it all boils
down to one question
do you enjoy hurting people it's only
after loki later realizes the
inconsequential nature of the infinity
stones within the tva that he's
completely honest with who he really is
by watching his own life and his brutal
death at the hands of thanos play out in
the time theater
he finally embraces the truth loki's
violence is a cruel elaborate trick to
make himself seem like a terrifying
person
so people will fear him even though he
himself thinks he's weak
oh loki you just saved yourself a very
expensive therapist bill
after loki's personal growth session
mobius reveals the real reason that he's
trying to work with him
there's another variant of loki running
around the timeline
killing the tva's hunters and generally
causing chaos
what's the best way of tracking down a
vicious variant of loki
use another variant to get a better
insight into the way the god of mischief
thinks
and why he constantly engages in this
level of violence
the thoughtful conversation mobius and
loki had will no doubt come in handy
when they eventually confront this
alternate version of the asgardian
if that even is the identity of the
violent variant
loki episode 1 then quickly cuts to
celina oklahoma in 1859
where a group of hunters go searching
for someone who's messed with the
timeline
and is trying to get rich by drilling
for oil in the past
oh if only that was the case a hooded
figure is revealed to be waiting for the
squad
setting them on fire with the oil in the
field in a brutal moment
this could be the same hooded figure
who's briefly seen in the loki trailers
the one many people are expecting to be
revealed as lady loki
since actress sofia di martino has long
been rumored to be playing the character
in the marvel comics loki has taken the
form of a woman from time to time
but it's typically being just another
form for the same character
if the variant the tva is hunting does
turn out to be lady loki
it'll be interesting to see how the
timeline diverged in a way to create her
how she escaped and what she wants but
we'll just have to wait a week to find
out more
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
loki are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]